how's gum Rosemeyer guess what
I can't believe I'm saying this I should
kind of like this game huh
when you when you're you actually
progress in it it's kind of Awesome
you feel kind of bad ice you're at night
five we have a phone call excuse me one
second oh okay I understand so we're
here for your ship yet but we'll work
we're going to try to contact the
original restaurant owner I think the
name of the place were red bears family
diner no you're talking about the other
place like it
one one bite hang in there all right
damn girl damn I don't know I'm saying
that until you let's see if we can beat
95 in not a million attempts like night
for the problem was that I didn't know
use the helmet properly but I know how
to use it now so who knows this might go
terrible or it's gonna go well I think
it will go I think I will have less
problem with night for the night 5s I'm
not too worried all right one [ __ ] in
the van hey baby girl how you doing I
miss I miss you man I don't know
anything about that guy I don't know
anything about that gang Jesus Christ
these guys go hard as my feet that
rabbit where do you got drop what you
kidding me this is gonna be impossible
what happened why do I keep saying
vagina in the ass in Swedish is that all
I got
vagina in the ass doesn't make any sense
for me to be saying that I ain't even
mad though I ain't even mad bro it's
like oh you were you were focusing too
much on the game well [ __ ] yo they keep
moving so much stop moving so much or
chicas here chicas here no [ __ ] if I
know anything oh oh [ __ ]
Dudley put the attack at the same time I
think I made it though oh [ __ ] he's here
now
gosh I was just love I was definitely no
thanks I will not [ __ ] I'm doing this
all for you brothers you know I'm trying
really hard for you hey Freddie I like
you hat you look like a real grade-a
douche you guys started attacking me
anymore I yeah it's not enough challenge
for you I myself AM Adira Oh father DLR
call me yang how am I suppose there's so
many member Berman how do I know if he
left or neither come on that's not fair
man I didn't even make you to 3 a.m.
this is gonna be so bad he's gonna be so
bad tefik
oh my god it's like I got this move and
hey I did better you look great yeah I
like your teeth
they remind me of Satan I like it a lot
now wait it's only 1 a.m. and I'm it's
so hardcore look at this [ __ ] ok there's
nothing going on maybe not now but
before I was really hard I got did I
hear something okay I hear two [ __ ]
sucking in my pee now what do you why
who are you like are they related oh
[ __ ]
oh come on come on I pull down the too
early by accident
come on so [ __ ] focus it's [ __ ]
ridiculous how far can you have to be
when you play this too bad I was ready
for you you little [ __ ] just [ __ ]
chicken how about you lose some weight
maybe then you can become a [ __ ]
model like I am oh god he's waiting well
I don't even know what's going on in the
vents anymore man I don't know if I was
fast enough I would say that there's a
chance see like
sometimes ah ah it really don't give you
a lot of time okay it's like the
weirdest gameplay ever like what am I
doing here
seriously what it what is this
if only that [ __ ] music box wasn't
there if only so scared I'm so scared
how am i God so much horror
iiiiii this is the one I can feel it in
my nipples those are not my nipples what
a [ __ ] did he come from
imagine this game on oculus rift I would
get you would literally get a sexually
transmitted disease or some [ __ ]
I'm not even close I don't understand
how am I supposed to do is I'm I'm
literally trying my heart out and I just
can't I'm not good enough it's 2:00 a.m.
and I'm like I've been so lucky so far
it's even I made it here
yeah [ __ ] me then do you see that do you
see what I'm doing here what the [ __ ]
was that
what the hell I never seen that before I
can't move my mouse oh Jesus Christ
like what about it what is what is even
happening anymore why is he not going
away
put this up with him now for this oh my
god Oh 4ad that's pretty good I'm proud
of myself
haha for ya
Wow this game is easy maybe not that
easy but so I'm so focused my balls are
dropping I'm not even kidding come on
let me go to five
I'm happy for we make it a fire bye Wow
we're gonna make it to six we're gonna
make it to six
I can feel it in my fingers I feel it in
my toe I'm not gonna [ __ ] die here
not gonna [ __ ] door
ah what am i doing summers suck my ass
suck my ass suck my ass ah the [ __ ]
caring Oh Oh Zoe you see this gave me
honest game so he's all got a [ __ ]
paycheck hundred and twenty bucks
hundred and bucks and fifty see look at
this look at that game and he was
harassing me this whole time - this is
that's like ultra hard mode
love box you are not on camera you dirty
[ __ ] I got a [ __ ] story
I got her [ __ ] iron that [ __ ] oh my
god
so now you get the six night I I need a
medic alright press like this video and
I'll see you stay awesome Road